hi i'm nitin verma
i'm a postdoctoral researcher at the
university of haifa
i'm going to talk about our paper
erasure resilient sublinear time
graph algorithms this is joint work with
amit levy
ramesh krishnan as pallavor and sophia
raskolnikova
the main goal of our work is to model
and study
sublinear time algorithms for graphs
that are incomplete
in the setting of sublinear time graph
algorithms the standard assumption
is that an algorithm has query or sample
access
to input graphs
however this assumption does not
accurately reflect reality in some
situations
for example consider the case of a
social network
as represented here in a picture by a
graph
where vertices are users and edges
between vertices
denoting the friendships between users
now some of the users might decide to
hide their friendship for privacy
reasons
and an analyst accessing this graph
will not see such edges we call such
edges as being erased
from the graph
we consider representations of such
incomplete
or partially raised graphs as
adjacency lists with some missing
entries
denoted in this picture by a special
symbol perp
as you can see here
specifically for a fraction alpha
less than one a graph is alpha erased
if at most an alpha fraction of entries
in the adjacency lists is adversarially
erased
a completion of such a partially raised
graph
is a valid graph that is obtained by
filling in
the erased entries
our model is an adaptation to the case
of graphs
of the erasure resilient model defined
by
dikshitar and they defined it for
testing properties of functions
an erasure resilient graph algorithm
gets a parameter alpha which denotes an
upper bound on the fraction of erased
entries
and also gets query access to an alpha
erased graph
one of the kind of queries it can make
is that of a degree query
where the algorithm can ask for the
degree of a vertex
we assume that the labels of vertices in
an n vertex graph are
from 1 through n so the algorithm can
specify one of these numbers
and get the degree of the vertex
specified by that label
the second kind of query is called a
neighbor query
it is specified by a vertex v and an
integer i
the vertex v has degree at least i
then the answer to the query is the
eighth entry
in the adjacency list of v which may as
well be
an erased entry in case the degree of
b is less than i then the algorithm
receives
a special symbol
the performance be it running time or
query complexity
of an erasure resilient algorithm is
measured
in the worst case over all alpha erased
graphs
i want to emphasize that these erasures
are made by an adversary
and the erasures are all made before the
algorithm starts querying
in our model we study two kinds of
computational tasks
the first one involves testing graph
properties
this field of study was initiated by
goldreich at all
where they considered graphs represented
by
adjacency matrices
later goldrich gold rayhanron studied
testing graph properties in the
adjacency list representation
where grants are assumed to have
a bound degree concurrently
pernas and ron studied in what we call
the general
graph model where graphs are represented
by adjacency lists
without any bound on the degree
our model is a generalization of this
general graph model by pronouncing wrong
testing in the general graph model has
been investigated
quite a lot and these are some of the
major works in that area
other task we consider is that of
estimating
a graph parameter in sub linear time
this is also a well studied area and
there are sublinear term algorithms
to estimate number of connected
components
degree moments and so on
next i will describe the specific
problems that we study
and also give an overview of our results
the first problem we study is erasure
resilient testing
property of connectedness
here an algorithm called an erasure
resilient tester
is given parameters alpha and epsilon
as inputs and also oracle access to an
alpha
raised graph g
the tester has to accept with
probability at least two thirds
if there exists a completion of the
graph g
which is connected
and the tester has to reject with
probability at least two thirds
if at least epsilon times m
edges need to be added to every
completion
of g so that it is connected
we say that such a graph is epsilon far
from connected graphs falling in this
orange region
and we refer to epsilon as the proximity
parameter
in the rest of the talk
this problem statement that we described
here can be generalized to any property
and not just
for connectedness for the purposes of
this talk
i will focus on connectedness
testing connectedness has been studied
for graphs with no erasures
and there the prior best tester
best epsilon tester for proximity
parameter epsilon
has query complexity 1 over epsilon d
the whole square
where d bar denotes the average degree
we study a ratio resilient testing of
connectedness
and show the following
surprisingly when the fraction of
erasures alpha
is larger than the proximity parameter
epsilon
one needs linearly many queries in the
number of vertices
this is in contrast with the upper bound
on the query complexity
that has no dependence on the input size
when there are no erasures
i would like to mention that the graphs
used in our lower bound construction
are very sparse and that this query
lower bound we obtain
is also really linear in the number of
edges for those graphs
when alpha is smaller than epsilon we
obtain testers whose complexity is
independent of the size of the input
just as in the case of no erasures
we further show that when alpha is even
smaller that is at most
epsilon over 2 we can obtain
further improvement in the query
complexity
to summarize we observe a phase
transition
in the complexity of connectedness
testing when the fraction of erasure is
alpha
is at least epsilon versus the case when
alpha is smaller than epsilon
in one case the complexity is linear
in the size of the input representation
and in the latter case
it is independent of the size of the
input graph
in the special case of graphs containing
no erasures
the complexity of our tester is better
than the complexity of the prior
best tester in a recent unpublished work
we observed that
our upper bound is tight
the second problem we study is that of
estimating
the average degree of a partially raised
graph
in the special case of graphs with no
erased entries
this problem has been studied by feige
goldrich ron and eden atom
pages showed that one can get a 2
epsilon approximation for the average
degree
of a graph by making only root n over
epsilon degree queries
this is an interesting result since for
an arbitrary list of
n numbers with values ranging from 1 to
n
minus 1 it is not possible to obtain
ends of linear time a good estimate for
the average
vega also showed that using just degree
queries
it is impossible to get anything better
any any better approximation guarantee
in sublinear time
in a subsequent line of work
goldrich and ron and eden natal
state of the art and obtained
one plus epsilon factor approximation
algorithms
making big o of
root n degree and neighbor queries
specifically these algorithms only
require access to uniformly random
neighbors of specified vertices
we design algorithms and prove lower
bounds for estimating the average degree
of
partially erased graphs
in particular we give a square root and
query algorithm with approximation ratio
1 plus
epsilon plus 2 alpha when the fraction
of erasures
alpha is less than half
additionally we show that this term of
alpha in the approximation guarantee
is essential by showing a linear query
lower bound
for approximating to within a factor of
1 plus gamma
where gamma is smaller than alpha
our result can be seen as unifying the
model with only degree queries
as studied by phi gay and the model with
both
degree and neighbor queries as
considered in the later works
specifically when alpha is equal to zero
there are no erasures and we obtain a
one plus epsilon approximation
in big o of roots and queries
when alpha increases from 0 to half
or to 1 it can be seen
as as progressively losing access to
some of the
neighbor queries and inching towards the
model
with only degree queries
in the rest of the talk i will give a
high level picture
of our improved connectedness tester and
its correctness analysis
for simplicity i will consider the
special case that alpha is equal to 0
or the case of no erasures
just to recall the problem is the
following the tester gets
inputs epsilon the proximity parameter
and d bar the average degree it gets
query access to a graph g
on n vertices and images the tester has
to accept with probability two thirds
if g is connected and has to reject with
probability two thirds
if g is epsilon far from connected
whereby epsilon far
i mean at least epsilon m edges need to
be added to g to make it connected
the basic algorithmic idea of goldrich
hyundron
for this problem to solve this problem
is as follows
basically design a tester that rejects
only upon finding some witness to g
being not connected
that is reject only if we detect a small
connected component
they observed that if g
the graph is epsilon far from connected
then
it has many connected components
and the testing idea is to detect some
such component
by running breadth first searches
from uniformly random vertices
we focus on graphs that are far from
connected and make a few more
observations
that will help us in designing our
tester more concretely
so here i've just written the earlier
observation
by goldberg and ron
the next observation is that it is
impossible
for many connected components to have a
lot of
vertices each that is
there cannot be too many large connected
components gold right under ron
call a connected component small if it
has at most
2n over epsilon m vertices and show that
a graph that is far from connected has
to have at least
epsilon m over two small connected
components
um we denote in the rest of this talk
this quantity 2 n over epsilon m
as b the symbol b and
use the term size of a component to
indicate the number of vertices in that
component
the next idea is to partition as a
mental experiment
these small connected components into
log b buckets
based on their sizes in a geometrically
increasing manner
and the next idea is
a work investment strategy by burma
natal
to make things clear the result
of birmingham implies that
given such a bucketing of small
connected components
if we iterate over
i from 1 through log b and sample b
over 2 to be a uniformly random vertices
from the graph
with high probability there exists some
iteration
in which some vertex from that it
somewhat exampled in that iteration
falls into the ith bucket
and this might help us to detect
a small component belonging to that
bucket
and using these ideas we now describe
the prior best connectedness tester
the tester gets inputs epsilon
and d bar and has query access to graph
with average degree d bar
the algorithm really looks like the work
in the investment strategy we iterate
over i
from 1 through log b and in the ith
iteration
we sample b over 2 to the i uniformly
random vertices
and run bfss from each such vertex
until either a small component is found
in which case we reject because we have
found a evidence to the graph
being not connected or either
a pre-specified query budget is
exhausted here the query budget is set
to 2 to the 2i neighbor queries
which is really the number of queries
sufficient to explore
a small connected component in the ith
bucket
and recall that a small connected
component in the ith bucket has
at most 2 to the i vertices and can have
only at most 2 to the 2i edges
this tester never rejects graphs that
are
connected if a graph is
epsilon far from connected by the work
investment strategy
with high probability there exists
an iteration i in which the sampled
vertex
falls in the ith bucket and in that case
the algorithm will detect a small
connected component
because our query budget is sufficient
to fully explore
that small component and the algorithm
can reject now here
is our connectedness tester what we do
is to simply replace the query budget in
the
ith iteration
from 2 to the 2i to something else
specifically
we replace it with the degree of the
sampled vertex
times 2 to the i where 2 to the i
denotes the size of the connected
component
that we hope to see in the ith iteration
to argue that our tester is correct
we only need to show why this query
budget is sufficient to fully explore
a small connected component
the intuition is that the expected query
budget that we
allot is equal to the number of edges in
that component
where the expectation is over the
vertices in the connected component
essentially we are replacing the worst
case bound of 2 to the 2i on the number
of edges
with some average case bound
and the rest of the correctness argument
will follow as before
by applying the work investment strategy
that with high probability we will
fall into the with high probability
in the i there exists an i such that in
the i th iteration we fall into
the eighth bucket and we will detect a
small component
the expected query complexity of our
tester can also be worked out
to be the desired expression by
simplification
here is the final upper bound that we
obtain in our paper
our final tester runs either the prior
known best tester
with complexity one over epsilon d bar
square or
the tester that i described just now
and the choice is made based on the
relative values of the average degree d
bar
and the proximity parameter epsilon
the complexity of this final tester
is better than the prior known best
bound
when the average degree is smaller than
square root 1 over epsilon
this is interesting because large graphs
of interest often are sparse and have
low average degree
and this improvement might help in such
scenarios
so far i described the connectedness
tester for the special case of graphs
without a ratios
when the fraction of erasures alpha is
small
we show that there are several small
erasure free connected components
and the same strategy we described works
however when alpha is at least epsilon
over 2
there need not be any connected
component without erasures
and we cannot apply the earlier strategy
in this case we redefine our witness to
not being connected
to be sub graphs some special sub graphs
that form a unique connected component
in every completion
of the input
and we observe details in our paper
we observe that we cannot apply the work
investment strategy with these kind of
witnesses
uh and thereby we obtain a larger query
complexity
our work raises several open problems
one immediate question arising from the
connectedness testing result
is whether the secondary phase
transition
in the complexity of testing at
alpha is equal to epsilon over 2 is
inherent in
the second question concerns monotone
properties
a graph property is monotone if it is
preserved under deletion of edges and
vertices
many important graph properties are
monotone
for bound degree graphs represented by
their adjacency lists
we observe that erasure resilience can
be obtained
at a factor at a cost
of square square of degree bound in the
query complexity
it is interesting to study the cost of
obtaining a ratio resilience for
monotone properties
of general graphs
the next question is a modeling question
our model is quite general in that
an entry b can be erased from
the adjacency list of a vertex u
but this entry u can still be present in
the adjacency list of the vertex v
one can call such erasures as asymmetric
we ask whether testing becomes easier
if one assumes that erasures are always
made in pairs or
in some sense symmetrically that is if v
is erased from the list of u then u is
also erased from the list of v
is such a model of
any help in improving the complexity
another question concerns
the relative power of the tolerant and
erasure resilient testing models
for delta parameters delta less than
epsilon a delta epsilon tolerant ester
aims to distinguish between graphs that
are delta close to satisfying a property
that is
these graphs can be made to satisfy the
property by changing
at most delta m edges
and to distinguish such graphs
from those that are excellent for from
satisfying the property
dikshitar tal observed the tolerant
tester
for a function property can be converted
to an erasure resilient tester for the
same property
their argument is that a tolerant tester
can be run on a partially erased
function
as is and whenever an erased point is
queried
this can be replaced by an arbitrary
value
but replacing erasures with arbitrary
values
does not work if the input is an
adjacency list representation
so their argument does not work for the
case of graphs
it will be really interesting to figure
out the exact relationship between
erasure resilient and tolerant models of
testing properties of grams
i would like to thank you for your time
and for listening to me
thank you